something that
i don't know if we're going to be able
to put out or not but you're in l.a
helping you were helping kanye write
some [ __ ] yeah
i'm doing a little ghost you know
collaboration
man i'm just you know i'm in a room for
the for the for the vibe
man and the inspiration yeah all
other kanye [ __ ] aside he's one of the
greatest artists of all time
um and i'm curious how did the
relationship with you and like how did
you end up
in that decision somebody else that i've
forgotten that i consider
kanye like a real friend you and kanye
you consider him a friend
yeah absolutely well you've been around
him recently how do you feel like is he
like good is like he in good spirits
like
he's in good spirits but it's like see i
don't know because i
i had i didn't know him prior prior to
what people would say him changing and
going
you know going left you know what i'm
saying so i don't know but just me being
around a man i know his heart
i know i know i said that on twitter the
other day i'm like yeah
he got a good heart right he he he you
know he mean
well i i'm gonna be just totally a
thousand percent honest
i feel like he just need you know some
better
some better guys in his circle you know
what i'm saying
yeah i saw somebody say like yo man like
some better dude sometimes
you you gotta you gotta listen and
respect them dudes and you know that
it's all
they telling you signing criticism
because they love you because they love
you
you know what i'm saying but i just hate
to see like the all the jokes and
you know i mean the social media
ridicule man of my brother man cause
like
you know what i'm saying he going
through some things man you know what
i'm saying and
we all go through it in life and of
course i'm not you know
trying to condone or make no excuses and
[ __ ] for him but
i love that man and i'm you know i mean
it's like when i got love for people
even if i don't know you or whatever
like i just love everybody i got more
love in my heart than and then hate
so like i'm not here to tear and tear a
[ __ ] down and tell him what he can't do
or you know you crazy you tripping
like when he announced i was i was you
know i'm saying um
on a wrench when he and you know he
called me and said i was in the studio
he's like yeah i'm gonna just
check the twitter i'm just running for
president you were in wyoming right
when i got that's what and then i
started seeing like twitter you know
what i'm saying
um like you know just the the ridicule
and all that making fun of that man and
i just look at [ __ ] like that's our
problem man in the community
like we we we too quick to tear tear
somebody down
and to kind of build them up i don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] say man i'm a mother
man
build me a house on the moon i'll be
like i know that [ __ ] gonna be fly
bruh hell yeah do that [ __ ] i'm just one
of them type of [ __ ] i ain't negative
like tearing nobody down